[Music] let
me introduce myself my name is carlos jiménez
I am working on orange well everyone
knows orange because many of them are from here in
córdoba I am working
particularly on the spin-off that
opened in buenos aires it is a
virtual wallet and we are going to say that it is the  great
technological commitment that the
galicia group is making for the development of
solutions, that is to say, we
like to say a lot that we are masters that the
end if the market is known as a
fintech but we say we are more tests than
weekend I am working there in the team
the role  that I currently have is from sidi
is today now I am going to show you
if you have with your cell phone you can scan
and you will see my linkedin you can access
I am as if they were dealing with each other said fisher
that is a fairly
new responsibility in fact in argentina I think we
are one because  basically that's what that
's a message if you want to say that
a person is working on
decision-making and participates in a table of
a table  strategy of a company with
one with a technical background
means that the company has taken
very seriously what is the commitment to
data and to the future of the use of
machine learning, yes, that is, if they want to
mean that, data science
officer chips will have  heard a lot about
chief analytics and silver officer and the
message that a company gives through
having that role means we
are serious and when we sit down to
make decisions and some strategic actions we
participate with that view
of technology and use  of machine
learning for solutions, although
today the idea is to tell you a little
about best practices, you saw that the
title is best practice, that is, best
practices in data science, it does not
mean that everything I do is fine and
everything I do is  team is fine
means that we are going to share
experiences that in fact I was seeing
I was seeing in the different in the
different talks that they usually mention  Oning
some tips of best practices,
for example, I had heard of the
random seed
act, being able to have traceability to be able to reproduce results, in fact, the
reproducibility of technical models is
a pain point for
insurance companies that want, for example, to go back
in time and return  to take out a prising they
don't have to reproduce for regulatory reasons they
have to reproduce at the
same price, for example, then there is
a series of recommendations, a
set of recommendations that are
usually made so that the
best practices for developing
solutions within the framework of  data science
some agree on a
recommendation that they would make to all this
public on best practices in
data science I just raised my
hand I said tell-tale seed, yes
well that is part of the procedure and
another one of the recommendations that you
would make if you  today they have the
responsibility to recommend best
practices for a  team that is going to
develop machine
learning solutions saw how they are implemented in
production in, for example, in amazon
in google in asur what would you recommend and
I am going to give you
[Music]
that the data that the data source is
perfect carbayín garba south perfect
someone else
trachea or the bases
if doing traceability of the
data set that was not very good lower is
welcome well now I am going to give a
series of tips that can help us
when implementing solutions in the
context of machine learning if then
how many  from here they heard about
cookie cater
ok 10% or 10% of the
statistical references are wrong that dro
how many heard about one well
should not surprise me because that dro
launched months ago that is to say at the beginning
of April what they did pedro basically
is a  solution that removes the
quantum black team from machines and boom at 15 and
buys quantum black which is a
consultancy that develops
solutions for  data science and
advanced analytics they developed
their own their own version of cookie
cater they took there
I'm going to tell you a little bit about what
it is about sit down and see let's go by
parts
here
come all
perfect
let's put cutter data science
what you are looking for is  science is complicated
this started in 2015 so they
developed a dry bandage team
this is an organization that
supports non-profit projects for
social good and they took a
framework called cookie cookie
cater and converted it to  cookie caster
for data science yes this is their
repository the original repository
and they are going to see what it has I am going to go
into each of the parts little by little and they are
going to see what this
cookie caster is about then I am going to
compare what dro to the development that the
quantum black guys did and I'm going to
show you a youtube video of nothing is
one of the developers of cedar that
good we were in contact  these days
what you can make us a video for the
page is hooked and there he made us
a video and I'm going to show it right away
so look how easy it is to
install cookie qatar
come on everything is already installed so what
I'm going to do is create  I am going to create
a repository from scratch if the idea is
that when you finish this
talk you know how to use
cookie cater because using cookie
qatar what are some of the
best practice tips for working in
teams
that compare with which dro choose between
broke  and kubica everything you
want and you can take that as a
result if that is the objective of the
talk I would love to be interrupted
if I would love for us to be able to chat
discuss raise your hand and not be
a monologue so let's start
I'm going to  stop at the correct folder
well that's it
then I wanted to show you the structure
of the talk
we're going to see in this introduction we're going to
talk a little bit about cook and qata  r what
this tool is about I am going to show you
is the presentation video that did
nothing to us yetunde and then we are going to see a
little about what dro is about and make a
comparison well
up to there any doubts
well then notice that you install pipe
install cookie cater  and now what I'm going
to do is take cookie qatar from the
repo to create a new project yes yes
yes
there it looks better
I don't think we
're going to do the following
it looks a little better there
so what I did was the following
cookie chair  it's installed with pipe
cookie cater and called from the
repository the structure if executed it
tells me to download it again and what we
're doing now is taking a
directory structure from the
git hub repository and we have to
choose a name for the project if
we are going to put test cookie cater
that is the name of the project now it is
the name of the repository if we are
going to logically create a
git repository or some version manager  s
in this particular cookie cater uses gips
then we are going to put test cookie cater
author we are going to put gandalf
description some description and here the
first thing it asks us is the type of
license if we want the incidence
of mighty close
or if not no license  we put no
license well then it asks us if
we want to configure a bucket ds3 if
we are going to work with an
amazon connection for now no and some
amazon file is not an
amazon profile where it will logically have
all the configuration data then it
asks us  the interpreter with which
we are going to work and we accept
then notice that there it appeared you can
see the background well
test cookie cater it appeared I discovered that
you have the folder I am leaving before cookie
cater
and this is the directory structure
that created it automatically if the
project is like  a template and imagine
how it is a template where we
fix all the content that we have
good the environment variables t  we have
git ignore
if we want to ignore a
particular folder the license the type of
license we choose the mail how many
here know make
ok perfect they know quite a lot about what an
orchestrator is a compilation
or execution manager if it is multiplatform
and how many already know if make  or have you
heard about simec simec simec
would be like an improved version of make it
is a little more contemporary maker is
quite old if those of us who know
linux use it a lot
and this is important there is a small
problem with make for windows and
that is that we have to configure a  environment in the
usa to be able to execute it yes
and that sometimes brings a bit of
headaches when we want to use cookie cater
in a microsoft environment does not
mean that it is not possible only that
the
corresponding environments have to be created so that they are installed
properly  make then we have the
mail
the mail is going to be responsible for
the whole set of operations that we are going to  We are going to
do it and there we are going to add
new commands if the commands that
we wanted to create are going to be there,
the project management will be there and now
I am going to give it, that is, I am going to show it
with an example, excuse me, run the
make command yes  If you want, let's go over
peep install cookie cater cookie cater
to the git challenge the git [ __ ] one sorry and
then the only thing I did now is
make nothing else between the make folder when
doing make it already shows me a
directory structure that structure sorry
a structure  of commands and that
command structure what it says is 1st
if you executed make link what it is going to do
is clean we are going to do it
making note that it deletes files that
are normally produced when executing
the payton scripts so in that
make link we can even
delete temporary files that
we configure we choose the type
of configuration let's suppose that they are
training models or are doing
some report and generate  ran
temporary files that you suddenly want to
clean all that and keep the
repository clean do make configure
the extensions and clean completely
yes create environment what you are going to do
is create a conda environment yes
later for example make that asset data
for example us  we are going to configure
a file that is going to be called make that to
do now I am going to show it and
basically what it is going to do is when
executing the make data command it is going to
look for the files that can be, for
example, those of amazon take a look at what
I just showed you  which could be a
ds3 configuration I am working
locally I do make data it brings me the
information from amazon the download can
be a sample not to mention
very large volumes I download a
sample and start working in my
local repository or directly through an
s 2 in  in amazon
good link I don't work much with flex I
don't want to talk about that topic if you have a
question I'm sure any of
you can answer it  sponder after requirements
logically is the requirements of
the package or payton repository,
that is, if I execute make requirements it
will install all the libraries that
my project uses and now we are going to
go in and see at the code level how
each one is done  no later to
perón here is the one without data
without data is this the ds3 and the data that
I put above that I am going to show it now
is a payton script that we
wrote them we wrote them to generate for
example it said just train and text well
when I do  data can take the
data and divide it into train and text if
when I do 5 it brings me all the
information twice until I
ask a question yes
with google cloud no not said note that
in 2015 they were making
updates these last few months but they are
fix  and they removed many things
that were not very very useful within the
repo if you can see it there in the git lab
the git hub but it's like there is not much
contribution yet yes still  there is no
integration with cloud this and then they
wish byron mind it is a test that is
going to pass now because I don't have code it is
I don't have any code prepared so we are
going to see the tri if the little tree in
this color is
going to want to kill we are going to  do one
thing he selected it not either when
ok but the structure I am counting the
structure has the license the make fai
and within data we are going to do like this to see
if I can solve it in some way
so
the structure data to our rock
has those best  practices of having
the external data on the one hand the
interim the data that was already
processed the interim sorry it is an
intermediate stage the
processed data that there is normally
the master tables are thrown away the training the test and
the roda is not
later we have the two quanta  from here they
know springs
it sounds like spinks spins well enough
good the tool is usually very popular
but spinks is one let's
look for it on the internet it seems to them
spins
payton if it is  What this tool does
is it allows us to
automatically document all the code that we do if
we put certain strings after
we execute spinks and what we are going to do
is generate automatic documentation it did
not happen to them that they get to work and have
a lot of scripts inside the
repository and hits and they have to
pass it on to someone it's a huge job and they
have to spend days telling them
what they did a good practice it's already
a tip is every time they build a
function they put the purpose of the function
and if they really want it  to your
colleagues put the input output if it is
very big there is a phrase that they used to
tell me that it was always you have to
program thinking that a serial killer
back we are going to keep your code and he knows
where you live if you mean we don't want him to
get angry then we try to  programming
always thinking of the other person
then if we
properly document if we simply put the
purpose inside the f  unction and then
we see it inside spins when
we execute spins it will generate a
beautiful web page it
has for each link in fact we can
do it for each link it has what are the
files the modules the input output if
that is the documentation then
logically the  models there it says models
believe me I'm going to put it here
models models that's in the
main folder if we're going to do one
thing I'm going to do something easier I'm
sure you've already thought about it but no one
said it we're going to open the desktop here by
data
scooter  and I can't run it or if you
can enlarge the
visualization,
well, then in the main folder
there is a folder called models, which
is what we are going to store the peaks there,
for example, the models that have already been
trained, I save them there, yes, and then
in the  source code we are going to have another
folder that is down here it is here it says
source
I am going to tell you why this happened I
normally do not have the syntax
highlighting the syntax  s but I thought it was going
to be too monotonous to show you and all of a
sudden I throw the colors away it is a
basic issue so in the source that we have
in the source data here is the make data
set that I mentioned today if I execute
make data it will  generate the rate that
I need I can execute the features and
here are the models so we have on the
one hand models inside the source code if
inside the shows where we are editing
our code there is a folder
called models and another models that is
outside
because outside what I am going  to save are
the trained models and inside all
the necessary templates to re-
train the technical models up to that point
some questions follow me well and then
visualization
well then what we were seeing
is the directory structure of
cookie cater and now this does not end for
us
we install the structure we have the
directory structure 7 we have a
git repository if it can be git
havlik git lab what you use and
we are synchronizing the repositories
but what is the number one rule of
versioning for data science models
some birds
or what would never
do I don't know who speaks for me yes
no version would you make the beak that you say yes
well there is the key ready the  key that
is the number one rule number one
when you work as a team and
are developing models is not to
version binaries not to version bases
because someone knows why we
should not version bases or binaries
exactly it is not made for that what is it for
us here to do each  every time
one executes a kits command what
gitex does, it internally sweeps the
codes and sees if there was a change in fact
even it is usually said no
version we have the jupiter notebook
because the jupiters do not obtain metadata
and that metadata every time we make a
change  for here it is a new change but
the only thing the person did was open and
close the file then every time they
now made the file t  I
have to do a check out that doesn't fit
that file is not what we do we put it
in notebook and if we want there are
tools in fact that are being
used to remove the metadata and
tracker only that part of the code
if in fact there is one in jupiter  extension
how
yes but there is also a tool that
what you do is execute and
save only the country point only the
country point without the metadata of yes
yes
perfect there is that good one I did not
know it I knew the one from jupiter that
you  what you do is trachea directly
the pait point in that extension and every
time you open that pait point it raises
a whole jupiter it's like adding the
metadata in there are some questions it's
here guys
well follow the idea of ​​what cookie
cater is if you saw it  what a
cookie mold doesn't abide by what it does is
give us a standard structure that if
you go to work from here to the usa
to russia or any other country you
understand why they tell you take this is it
my project they are going to open the project and it
turns out that it has this structure yes
well let's see what else we have around here
we said data test environment this
we did it perfect well
let's see shows
well this is the same stress to the
data guys I promised I would  to open it from
data
we see data and the data set is the make data
set
that's good this is what I was telling you it does
n't look like plain text we are going to go a
little further here basically when you
install from scratch it gives us a structure
where it has the  calls to the bookstores
we are going to see a little further down for the
month and something is not understood about the idea
is that they take a
work framework here that can be implemented
tomorrow, yes, so if we have to
ask around, one encourages us  to ask and someone
else can do it so what we do
is here I stay here we import the
libraries we have a main a main function
and this is just an example
because it has no content and there are the
logs we can load  ar all the
logs and that way in the make data set
when they call it
in this make data set with the command
make make data this payton script is executed
if the logic of all these of
all this is simple
I have a structure of directories
I have  purposes for each of the
folders I have some folders that
I want after being in git to version
and share with my co-worker
and others that I do not want to version which
I do not want to version the data folder for
example he said to me for example the
models folder yes yes  I don't want to deal with
the models if they are all in binary
because there I can have a model, a
logistic regression or something simple that
is in plain text, the same as another or yes,
but in general I try not to deal with this
type of document, we are up to there,
good
now  I want to show how I am
I have audio from here no
yes
I have output
well
now I am going to introduce you to yetunde I
was very happy because she told me it
was the first time  that is presented in
Argentina that dro
is coming to the market in reality they
are the credit and excellent
hello locals older age is in English they
have attended to dictate for manager
continues black and the lizard stocks and
peace
is not good I think it is that it requires 60
55 am  true white and will smith on
wednesday the white entity followed by the
stand of very cool experts you do not have
to be in the barbican in directing
under fire difficult tank mansion they have
authorities manipulated
wikileaks bakker area to be carried out
that causes a team to
write on the internet  that would be my serious
for me it remains vertical
how sad
and not even the intense damage of the challenger
bake compex
in a matter
of 37 months they talk to me about jeans wahab
longer projects enrile expectation of
fractioning and each user you want is the
legitimate facebook barbarians uploads the
reason for  the arrest time continue
with xbox of intellectuals three
antecedents mining in liniers know one
news gates piques  this web service
and perhaps you also write it to
annoy interest expected only
strongly texas this is a gift
brown interaction facing existing
stakeholders that maintain the event will
extend to a record sale of we
deliver hast live vol-ras live tractor
so it is a vector
tenths  it was to enter experimentation
apart from the sprinter stock btt
observe they are experiments in pace of
america says enemy servility in the
head have environments and outside
waivers type also control city
monsters
sanders
ouija of sanders issues
is my website
james jones
[Music]
nextel
perico
wenders sorry doctor aiguader  axesor
documentation and they are very low
dyn I would
write young tuesdays they are fiction
and it is true
to see
mercury in barcelona metlife
as
i
and
well what counts and this is the
development of the state of the art that is why
I also wanted to share it with
you because it is the  state of the art
this is coming out now it is something that
is  it is in full development it is in
version 0.15 I think the only
question in start over flow is mine they
are just developing everything and it is
good that you already know it so
that you can participate in this community
begin to know the framework and also
that  you can make contributions from your
perspective this now I'm going to show you
know that something occurred to me while I
was speaking today this where
maybe
I can show you we are going to do the
following
I think with a
perfect jog and I can do something like this not
change the profile  of the terminal and I
can go to something like this it is a great
discovery that you have just made
I think that with standard it is no longer
there it is
perfect now
we are going to open one
rather a little better maybe
there
well
think about I am saying the commands
then there  it looks better a little
better and well now let's go with what dro
if you ran cedros install with peep
install which is very simple
here look at the first commands
remember that kubica ter that we did
kubica ter repo we brought all of us
the parameters we ignore the folders
we want to ignore and we start
working on it later we can execute in the
different makes the commands are all
with make those who use microsoft are going to
have to know it but  no
problem, you can, it's a little more tricky,
but what you have to do is leave aside
the doctor seeing this, the guys from
quantum black said and let's not use more
make so that it is cross platform and they
don't have to install anything additional
then we are going to create points
I'm not going to be fast I think I have 5
minutes it
's good because I get good right away it
's that
dro but look at the same logic name of the
project if we're making a like it's
a payton package python package very
wrong it's not good it doesn't matter
well I put for  to be able to start using
if I want to do a test we are going to do a
test ready now we are going to see here
and it does not go
well I have on the one hand I spit on you cater
lo  what we just did and on the
other hand test pedro
a test
pedro
so here we have the
directory structure of what dro you are going to see
many similar things because precisely
many similar things with cookie cater
because precisely what did the
guys from quantum black grab kubica
ter they improved some issues that
were much more comfortable for them,
such as the case that I just told you,
but they also added several
things and I am going to show you hopefully I will have the
time to show you something that is
fascinating
here if I do make it is not used anymore  make
executed pedro and it is going to show me the list
of commands same logic as cookie
cater so what we have here is that dro
install when something that dro install is going to
check the dependencies it is going to execute
the processes that it has to execute and
we have already
executed pedro that is  our when
we put all our code inside when
doing the install it will configure everything
that it has to configure and de  Well,
simply with a dro run, it executed
the process, which could be the process,
train a machine learning model,
put into production some series of
expert rules or whatever or any
type of operations that we are going to do
in a modularized way with python with a
that dro run 7 we love some clone or
whatever but we always call from there yes
then here it executed all the processes
and at some point I said who knows
if make because those who know if make
know that it is in the logic that shows
if make if they are  the different executions
in the order it shows it in
detail to the execution processes and
later, although of outbreaks where we test
our models, this system does not
confuse what is a text or a
cross validation of a model if we do not
want the implementation that we did
and we  it will give a result that
this is very interesting because it will
go through the entire repository it will look for
the chats or the blocks of
code that  I know that they were
actually executed and which ones were skipped, it is
understood because there can be many
comments or commented code all of a sudden,
I realize that in the coverage I am
using 51 percent of a
code that is enormous, it is evident to me
that  there is a lot of residual code yes
then it also helps us to understand
the structure of our directory well
as it is well then I do the last thing
that this is beautiful
the logic that this has if I can't
change it guys of color because they
did it so it is that  you are seeing here
what you are seeing here basically is
all the implemented code
but visually yes here the example that
pedro brings is the example of iris the
typical one but imagine now
that we implement we train a lot
of models in our repository
we have  a very complex structure and what
we do is drobiz and it visually shows us
all the
dependencies between the different modules.  The and it's
beautiful believe me to maintain this is
beautiful
this changes the logic and with this I close
we no longer think in modules but we
think in nodes because another of the
things that I loved that the
quantum black team did is instead of working
in form  modularized they created pipelines
where each module is actually a node
of a pipeline and that is what we
are seeing here yes well guys with
this I leave you here there is a lot to see the
truth that it is a very
interesting tool to explore and I hope
that you  help you to
develop your projects
to standardize the xii believe me that your
colleagues will thank you if you
work in a standard way
well we thank carlos there is room
for one or two questions because we are
very out of time some I want to
ask one  question
perfect well yes yes yes great and besides they
have integrated the fingers that you
also want, that is, one can lift
a doctor directly by commands  s
this we
want one more if there is one more
someone else has any questions
the place is finished off at one the huerna carmen is finished
off
with
beautiful work and of course one thing of work with
12 goodism
we tell each other
the anus for spider well nothing  more
pallarés for the two boys
well if one more
this
eternal what today is based on productions you
saw the folder that is out models
is that folder the one that votes to take the
production bolo that here what you do here
in fact it is the same it is also
thought about training the models is
correct what to say is not thought
well you are going to take all this the dow care
but you are going to take what you
need to be executed yes yes it is
correct what is thought for
the development of the training but  not
to bring all that to production
apart from it has a cost
[Music]